à la télévision plusieurs programmes
proposent la participation d'enfants et
d'adolescents
c'est le cas par exemple de prodiges et
de l'eurovision junior sur france 2 ou
encore de the voice kids sur tf1 allez
ce titre elle et c'est justement ce
dernier programme qui est aujourd'hui au
coeur d'une polémique satine jeune
candidate de l'émission en 2015 publie
aujourd'hui un livre dans lequel elle
révèle avoir été harcelés après sa
participation
[Musique]
des émissions avec des enfants ça a
toujours existé on se souvient par
exemple de l'école des fans sauf
qu'aujourd'hui la donne a changé
les enfants sont mis en compétition est
très exposé au jugement de tous sur les
réseaux sociaux devant des millions de
téléspectateurs
si je puis me permettre la prochaine
fois concentre toi sur ta chanson d'une
exposition qui peut être positive quand
les choses se passent bien mais qui peut
être dévastatrice pour les perdants
n'est donc pas toujours facile d'être un
enfant star quel que soit le domaine on
peut aussi citer jake lloyd le jeune
acteur incarnant anakin dans star wars
ou encore la star selena gomez qui ont
été victimes eux aussi de harcèlement
vis-à-vis de leurs camarades alors les
émissions d'enfants sont elles trop
dangereuse et on assassine qui est avec
nous à 10 ans elle participé at the
voice qu'ils commencèrent à massat il
adore cette couleur de cheveux à la 10 0
tu vas dans ces cerises insultes
harcèlement menaces coups et blessures
alors on rigole pas satiné a vécu un
enfer
après avoir fait de voice a été un truc
de ouf ça a été très très compliqué ce
qui s'est passé c'est à l'école jean à
l'école harcèlement scolaire en fait on
pense tous que c'est de la jalousie ça a
été quelque chose à presque dans
soutenable en fait ça a commencé par des
petites remarques
puis les remarques étaient plus
blessante puis ensuite c'était des
insultes et en fait ça finit par
dévoiler première remarque mois soit il
s'était tu te la pètes puis après c'est
devenu ouais tu prend la grosse tête
après c'était une [ __ ] [ __ ] des
rumeurs qui tournent les trucs insensés
c'est ça finit par des coups et au bout
des cours au bout du troisième court on
s'est dit c'est pas normal
qu'est ce qui s'est passé je reçois ces
des jeunes filles font me poussaient des
bandes faisait tomber on a foutu une
claque un coup de poing et au bout du
coup de poing on s'est dit c'est trop en
fait très peu alors à l'époque c'est un
rêve qui se réalise en plus pour toi
bien sûr il paraît que tous les soirs
vous regardez avec vos parents ouais bah
oui mais en fait on était trop fan on
adorait le champ je vais dire moi je
suis né dans la musique mais bon ça fait
genre 30 ans qui sont dans le milieu de
la musique comme ceux qui vous ont
appelé the way bah ouais c'est qu'ils
nous ont appelés de bazas on n'avait pas
une thune ne pouvait pas payer le trajet
pour aller à paris donc il nous en faut
et nous on fait sauter tous les castings
absolument tout pour parce qu'il voulait
absolument me voir en fait alors tu
participes à cette émission est ce qu'un
pays colloque qui t'a préparé
ouais alors il y avait un psychologue du
coup sur les plateaux sur le tournage on
avait genre des petits entretiens de 10
15 minutes par jour pour chaque gamin du
coup qui a été là bas
ouais alors qu'à prestation elle a fait
énormément parler ouais alors il ya eu
ce genre 20 millions de vues battant
avait même parlé avec qui fait trop de
risques et je regarde pas de ouf
ouais parce que j'adore les boys j'adore
les kits et mais malheureusement je n'ai
pas tf1 chez moi
non mais je trouve que dans mes se
retrouvent que sur tout et une
personnalité exceptionnelle
tu as quel âge maintenant maintenant
j'ai 16 ans j'avais 16 ans lie arbres
bon ça se passe mieux 30e là je suis en
première bac de français
trop tranquille en première fois en
première générale est à sortir un livre
satine d'ailleurs en sorte ya les vins
tu sais que toi je le verrai grave avec
nous ouais c'est vrai le jura les âges
il ferait grave d'avoir le retard est
bien d'une john fust ton âge h f
autour de la table j'adorerais méchante
c myc volontiers je me contente de la
semaine prochaine ou pas chaud chaud
alors au niveau de l'argent généré à
tignes je te tue c'est vrai les années
des tatas entre crainte et je venais
qu'est ce tu rougis déjà quelques
cheveux ça y est ils ont déjà dit on va
pas faire ravir tout le monde là dessus
mais je sais que géraldine est vraiment
ils sont jamais fan de ses émissions de
sur les enfin je veux la vie pour caviar
à tpm paix ou la vie sur ce qu'elle a
vécu sur ce qu'elle a vécu moi je suis
pas fan des émissions pour les enfants
ce qu'avant ça me dérangeait pas il ya
eu des clones l'école des femmes a été
content et a les notes et tous idée
géniale mais maintenant quand tu prends
le risque y as et je trouve que c'est
plus risqué qu'avant parce que
maintenant derrière il ya les réseaux
car il n'y avait pas les réseaux talent
à l'école des fans ton père ils
m'attaquent sa caméra qui filmait s'est
terminée là maintenant je trouve que
c'est un gros risque moi personnellement
mes enfants je ne serai pas mis dans un
truc de télé crochet the rape and us
qu'on peut pas mesurer la conséquence
derrière qui est dévastatrice tu te fais
insulter les terriens cesser les réseaux
qui font ça c'est ce qu'on fait et je
crois qu'elle est obligée de déménager
non alors oui j'étais obligé de
déménager mais quand même ouf non en
fait ça allait trop loin moi je me
disais ils vont tuer en fait mais sur
les rucks et qu'est ce qui est pire
le pire c'était vraiment le coup de
poing que j'ai réussi à esquiver pour le
cacher dans les chiottes parce que
vraiment mais c'était pas possible mais
donc c'est la jalousie qui a dû fuir
elle a dû déménager mais c'est un truc
de dingue à 8 heures dont les victimes
qui partent un violeur
mais c'est vrai qu'au camp quand on t'a
en plateau c'est difficile de dire non
mais moi je dis non parce que l'intitulé
de la question c'est les émissions
d'enfants moi je pense que les émissions
d'enfants n'ont jamais posé de problème
mais on se voit à la télé mais le souci
c'est les réseaux et on en revient
toujours au même non tu vas à l'école tu
as les réseaux qui vivent quand tu
rentres de l'école pas encore les
réseaux kitchen donc à un moment donné
il faut aussi
les chefs à bras le corps et ré résoudre
enfin ce problème de réseaux sociaux qui
foutent la foule dawa
le problème ça va c'est la selanne album
et là c'est la nature humaine
vous faites une émission de chansons
parce que vous avez une passion en lutte
pas contre la passion et effectivement
après c'est un dommage collatéral qui
suit s'il faut être extrêmement armes et
les autres dans tous les cas de la vie
il y aura des trucs comme ça la jalousie
la méchanceté
merci pour cette leçon je pense qu'il
faut un âge minimum parce qu'elle est
toute façon par exemple exemple de miss
france miss pense à 12 ans pour moi je
trouve que c'était même un peu trop tôt
j'étais pas prête
alors j'imagine jeune de 12 ans de 7 ans
on va les mener vers 10h à l'enfance et
l'adolescence j'ai déjà assez compliqué
pour encore mettre sa part ne suggère
pas d'argent pour harcèlement
malheureusement il arrive à tous les
âges c'est ça qu'il faut combattre et
pas les émissions essayé durant j'arrive
mieux à mieux gérer les enfants ne le
disent pas quand il soit un seul essai
au bout de chez sais pas combien de
temps et au goût de coups en tout cas
qu'on peut dire ouais en fait oui
sincèrement je pense que il n'ya pas que
les gosses qui font des émissions télé
pour enfants qui se font harceler
mais en tout cas lamela telle
médiatisation et le tel poids de la
pression qui assurent le sur les épaules
d'un gosse quand à 6 ans tu fais une
émission et que tu rentres à l'école je
veux dire les gamins et la race humaine
et non pas forcément
le fin quand tu es gamin tu as même pas
le temps de prendre du recul
donc évidemment tu t'en prends je m'aime
moi mais moi je vous dis la vérité j'ai
extrêmement peur force est bon pour mes
enfants parce que c'est vrai que l'on
vous êtes aussi le fils d'une personne
qui aide à un million qui sait comment
il peut exposer
on peut avoir des choses parfois en
classe et ça c'est vrai que je me
demande souvent est ce qu'on t'a parlé
de ça mais c'est vrai que ça c'est ça
c'est assez compliqué je me rappelle moi
c'est jean pierre mocky m'en parlait à
l'époque l'église et c'est vrai que ça
aussi il faut faire extrêmement
attention surtout quand vous avez pas de
pseudo il ya des artistes ils ont des
pseudos donc c'est pas le même nom là
l'enfant arrive à l'école c'est pas le
nom du droit voit la mer de la station
de moi je m'appelle nagui
d'ailleurs oui moi je veux que les
émissions d'ailleurs c'est votre frère
capillaire je n'ai pas cette couleur de
cheveux ya longtemps oui j'ai un succès
exact succès je pense qu'elles peuvent
être dangereux ces émissions quand elles
sont pas bienveillante et là dans
l'extrait c'est tina fey de juden
c'était une super prestation mais c'est
à risque et j'imagine car onze ans c'est
peut-être un peu moqué de toi parce que
ça sortait un pool de la norme et dans
l'extrait jennifer et patrick fiori ils
se moquent un peu toi ils comprennent
pas et sait et on n'a pas le droit de se
moquer et de ridiculiser un enfant dans
une émission nous avec delphine on a
fait une émission avec des enfants qui
ont fait de la magie on avait une
consigne fermé mais qui est extrêmement
justes c'est de ne pas rabaisser les
enfants de se moquer on se rend pas
compte des conséquences à l'école il
suffit que vous fassiez une petite
remarque un enfant il peut se faire
harceler dans la nature et aux bills al
hassani elena situation qui était avec
moi en parlait il ya quelques jours avec
les réseaux sociaux le harcèlement
malheureusement il continue en dehors de
l'école alors aujourd'hui ça va mieux
aujourd'hui ça va beaucoup mieux j'ai
déménagé maman je suis dans un lycée
j'ai des amis et genre je mène une vie
d'ado normale est vraiment tout va bien
mais aujourd'hui tout va bien je gère
les cours youtube le livre tout va bien
devoir semaine prochaine allez je te
kiffe incroyablement il est très peu au
clic maman tu mets et c'est super idée
merci je te fais des gros bidon
merci satine